welcome to the creation crystals portal  master here you can create your very own  imaginator  let's choose a battle class each class  uses a unique type of weapon these  imaginations are small and England  trained in the way of the throwing star  a new ninja is born now bring your  imagination oh hey nice to meet you  officer on the bridge it's ready ready  to roll color is a great way to make  your imaginator stand out choose an  overall color theme to quickly change  the look of your imagination  he wear of mine  you can make further changes to your  imaginator anytime you wish  tri-tip soldier tri-tip  okie-dokie fingers crossed and ready to  hop into the camera first you gotta  blast yourself out of that cannon Oh  what  a shot in the dark  since a supernova  was what I call a big bag only a sensei  can strike the battle goes only in  darkness the stone  star  daiji power ready  superstar  the stars have fallen on my enemies we  level off my stars have never